this is a story that I am really
interested in hearing your thoughts
about nyle sent me this story this is
potentially a huge story
no one's been talking about about this
I've seen no explanation for what I'm
about to show you here I think you're
going to like it
it looks like FoxNews may have scripted
a so-called debate between two people
that they had on last week this was on
John Scott's Fox news show called
happening now which as the name implies
is is a live program on Fox News the
segment involved a debate between Fox
News contributor Lisa booth and former
Bill Clinton campaign adviser Simon
Rosenberg they went on and the idea
again was eith quote debate about the
Trump Russia connections and the leaks
surrounding them so let me just show you
twenty seconds of what the segment
looked like just to set the stage for us
and it's important for us as a country
to get that not only do we need to
prevent it from ever happening again but
we also have to make sure we're working
with our European allies to prevent
Russia from continuing these kind of
activities in Europe in elections right
now but it seems like the media doesn't
seem that interested in the legality of
those leaks and so I think it's
important for Chairman newness to
mention that the fact that these
investigations are ongoing
okay normal Fox News segment it's a live
debate two people talking to each other
maybe not in this next clip I'm going to
show you and I understand if you're if
you're listening on the radio or the
podcast some of this is not going to
make total sense but I'll do my best to
describe what we're seeing on screen in
this next clip I'm going to show you pay
close attention to what Lisa booth is
saying and simultaneously look at the
text at the bottom of the screen if
you're not watching what happens is she
says there's been a lot of recklessness
in Trump's statements about the Russia
investigation and literally less than a
second later the bottom of the screen
says booth : there's been a lot of
recklessness in the discussion about
Russia how could they put up a title
quoting her half a second into a
statement during a supposedly live
unscripted debate okay watch the bottom
of the screen while you
listening to Lisa booth they said that
FBI director Comey will testify I
believe is on March 20th March 28th so
it's important for that to continue to
get to the bottom of this but more
importantly look there's been a lot of
recklessness to go around one you know
president Trump has a responsibility to
ensure that the information he's putting
out there is substantiative to be
careful in the language that he is using
a few seconds later it happens again and
it's even worse this time the caption
actually comes up before Lisa booth even
says it in the clip I'm about to show
you notice that the caption says booth
no evidence to support collusion between
Trump team and Russia it pops up before
she even says it it suddenly gets taken
down almost like the person running this
the graphics realizes oops she hasn't
gotten to that part of the script yet if
such a script exists and then puts it
back up again okay let's take a look at
this next book well you know so far you
know I hope that the White House
produces that information but so far
there's been nothing to substantiate
that so of course that's a concern I
also think it's equally concerning that
the media and the left have run rampant
with these allegations in the notion
that somehow Russia sold the election
for Hillary Clinton and in putting in
the hands of Donald Trump and also that
there's somehow collusion between Trump
officials in Russia when both of those
allegations remain unsubstantiated also
putting out information like the Russian
that docked the air the lower third
title saying that booth claims there was
no evidence so far to support collusion
popped up on the screen pat before she
even said it yeah that's really bad I
mean of course there is a chance that
this was pre-recorded or that they
edited the graphics and post but
assuming this is a live debate it seems
like they were giving a script to just
one side of that whole conversation so
the conspiratorial immediate reaction
would be
Simon Rosenberg the guy who is giving I
guess the more there's something to look
at between Trump and Russia side here
does not seem to have been scripted lisa
booth of the Fox News contributor
appears to be scripted the graphics
people seem to already know what she's
going to say in the so-called debate
not really a debate the way we would
normally understand it that really in
and of itself should also raise eyebrows
but the fishy thing about this is not
that it's just her talking that seems to
be known in advance it's that this is
set up as a debate a more liberal person
Simon Rosenberg is debating a specific
issue with someone taking a more hey
nothing to see here folks type of point
of view and it seems as though Fox News
was already privy to what she would be
saying
Simon Rosenberg III would guess wasn't
privy to it whether he was or wasn't
doesn't really change this is this
actually a debate or is this just a set
up and is it fair and balanced I think
there yeah definitely a place for having
a scripted segment on live TV if the
anchor is speaking directly to the
camera for example that's totally fine
but when you're conducting an interview
or holding a debate I mean there's the
assumption that people are speaking
genuinely from their heart from their
memory and that they don't just have the
text in front of them I think the bottom
line that you're pointing to is if this
is being represented as hey here's an
issue people can disagree on let's have
a debate between the two people on the
issue if one person is showing up and
just reading a script for their
positions it's not really a debate and I
think that's what's most damning about
this you know I don't think I can trust
Fox News as a reputable all of a sudden
oh yeah
people started tweeting me a couple
viewers are aware Nile sent this to me
and then a couple other viewers
seemingly heard about it somewhere even
though I wasn't able to find any reports
about this I would suggest we start
tweeting John Scott and Lisa booth and
it Simon Rosenberg and say can you
explain this send them a link to this
clip on YouTube and say can you explain
this is it possible that this wasn't
live at all I don't know what the answer
is here if you're listening please check
out the video version of this story on
our TV show or on YouTube because the
visuals really tell the whole story